alors comment les parisiens ont ils
appréhendé cette petite révolution
la réponse en images avec marie aline
melli et olivier palomino rouler
décontractée c'est un peu là vélib
attitude cet après-midi les vélib les
vélos libre-service de paris était à
tous les carrefours
mais pour profiter de la balade estivale
encore faut-il pouvoir retirer un vélo
mais non ça marche pas
si vous y arrivez là oui péniblement la
deuxième fois c'est bon
pas toujours facile d'apprivoiser le
système informatique ou encore
d'enfourcher un vélo de 22 kilos quand
on a perdu ses vieux réflexes
rouler sur les grands axes parisiens
sans piste cyclable continu et parfois
un exercice périlleux
il est faux
mais voilà dans la jungle parisienne
on ne s'improvise pas cycliste du joug
bolom premières impressions après
quelques minutes à vélo
comme bénin
vraiment déçu bien pourquoi
fin de la balade ont dix minutes plus
tard tu mets à n'importe quelle borne
pour montrer
sais pas on verra arriver bon ok je vais
m'entraîner au vélo d'avoir chez moi
voilà bonne journée
pas sûr que les parisiens abandonne tout
de suite le volant pour le guide au
seulement 1,5 pour cent d'entre eux
utilisent le vélo pour leurs trajets
quotidiens